I'm trying to emphasize to you like what
way to these steps come from like how
did I knew no too big
well the question told me use that focus
directrix that mean how do I know to do
this why they need to get ppso kids
naturally into the same equation so
that's why I equated it we'd never do
the next slide well I just want I got
looking at so would one more time tree
you see the steps inhale across to them
alright last month the introduces pair
of angles now they've already put it
onto their diagram I haven't just yet
because we only needed it now all right
he's alpha right in there okay and beta
is beside it in there okay
there are either side of the normal do
you see that where they are where
they're situated and that's critically
important by the way as you see the
minute okay let off a equal that being
that by applying the same rule man why
did they give you a hand right but many
of the HSC questions they'll do this
although say use this result but prove
it okay the emphasis is not on depth
algebra because that's what these
questions become otherwise they try they
really want you to get the answer so
read carefully and use the clues by
applying the sine rule show that okay so
my diagram in here I'm going to try and
do it one kid so firstly here's the
first triangle yeah they're calling it s
- Mk I think or s that PN whichever
order doesn't really data
so I'm gonna say in that triangle right
because I'm about to break the cycle
twice so I want to say how I'm doing it
so in triangle s - P and now we don't
want to get you why won't you show that
Alfred meter the same angle how am I
going to do it the way that I need to
show this is by using the sine rule I'm
not obviously going to have to take
value just sign up and sine beta and
show some kind of equivalence between
those right so therefore whichever side
will ratio I choose sign up has got to
be involved okay so I need to do that
which other sides do you think I should
compare like I've got some choices I've
got to use sign up like so that means
yes that has to be used right and then I
have a choice between P s - or p.m.
which do you think is a better choice
clearly PS - what's the clue that tells
you what's the clue and the clue is
flashing like a big where black part
three right I'm looking back to here
they've got a relationship between you
two I get something to use this somehow
right don't be arbitrary use the primal
it okay so therefore I'm going to say
how did I write which one let's start
with okay so there's PS - there I'm
going to Paris I'm gonna this is the way
by the way I'll put the X just so I
don't like muck up the signs on that
angles I'm pairing up I put an X to the
side I'm off dong and then I draw the
air and Elpis it just so I don't get
good service - divided by sine of p and
he goes - yep
I'm gonna try to avoid naming more
things because I've already got now
furtive eater in there obviously you can
do it however you like but I mean I
generally steer clear of introduced
Incredibles where I don't have to I
could they have a low-flying Gregory
okay now what was the other ratio I'm
kind of stuck I have to use a particular
one I need Alfonso in that gives me this
side compared to that angle
what's that okay that right so let's do
it so that's going to be a nice - on
sign oh [ __ ] never that okay I usually
need a gap for a second I don't really
know what I'm going to do with this just
yet okay but I do know I've got to use
the silo in the other triangle and then
see how I can free these together so I'm
going to say well leaving into space
okay
because I don't know how to simplify
that just yet let's look at this other
triangle here let me complete it
okay so there's the triangle and again
I've got to compare the pairs of sides
that will give me some useful results so
I don't have any choice here I want to
compare em as we've been on and which
other side entities
yeah just pants because that's the other
part of the ratio that so there's PS and
I'm comparing it with P and s so
therefore in triangle P and s economic
similar statement
I've got PS on that angle
ok firstly I'm gonna say apply secondly
yes I am in a second ok
because for this step what I want to
really make on this is I know which
sides are which and I'm not getting the
confused so before I go to that bit like
I just know it from my own experience I
will probably mark that up if I do those
two in at the same time ok but if you
can't you're welcome to because that
would be helpful in a second what was
the other side I was paying with an X
right in s and sign me up
ok so pause for a brief moment I have
these two things I've done what they
told me to do I have used sine rule in
both the triangles but now the question
is well what do I do with each of these
ok
anyone want to give a suggestion what I
could
now interestingly I think you guys know
more than you're probably giving already
right I need to simplify these in some
way the question is what way shares
simplify out okay
now in my head when I first approached
this question and there were two things
that were going through my mind I
thought we clearly sign out for in San
Beda
they are reporting they matter right
I've got to get to alpha equals beta in
a minute so I assume that means it's
after a meter the same then sine alpha
sine beta are also the same right but
problem is I don't remember that yet
right like that's going to be the last
line not the first line so I can't
really take advantage of that make you
sign up for the sign media the subject
not particularly useful at the moment
then came my second four have a look at
everything we've done so far right look
at part one part two and part three
what did they tell me that you might be
able to do with these
this equation is psi n this equation is
a PS - if there's an NS errors - if I if
I combine be some way through division I
can take advantage of this right so
you're going to help me and this you can
either make PS PS - the ratio or you can
make in this in its natural division
doesn't matter just cuz I brought on the
left hand side I'm going to make PS -
the subject t and PS the subject let's
do that
okay
so you see what I thought this is just a
straight substitution yeah and I've
introduced the division sign so at a
fraction of fractions because my brain
hurts a little bit at this point right
there's the SSPs - I've done the
division now in order to get at what's
going on can you see there are so many
terms here but they're all paired up do
you notice that every single term is
paired up so to make those relationships
we clear up I'm just going to rewrite
that right hand side so they can see
what period we want for instance I have
an SM on the numerator here but
corresponding to that I have an NS
that's on the denominator gcx I'm
dividing so I'm gonna write that as and
as on as - then I've got these other two
angles in here sine PMF and some pianist
- they clearly pen up as well right so I
have this one we have two - on the
numerator and then up on this one with
me - on the denominator not that man is
as you citizen and then lastly I have
this mysterious sign up inside bead on
this guy's gonna kick hop onto the
numerator that guy's gonna stand in
Timonium
how we looking okay now we are within
grasping distance okay have a look again
I've been including you into it how am I
going to use pop3 in this am I gonna use
it yeah very good
these two are the same thing right these
are the same thing so therefore all I
have to do is to say well this is PS
over PS - but this is PS MFPs - as well
right from part 3 so therefore in a
second once I finish writing this line I
can just cancel those two out that's
really good okay secondly I'm gonna take
the cutest suggestion right which is
that we know what I'm actually gonna buy
us need to be England just to make it a
bit clearer because I don't know about
you but I didn't see the connection as
quickly as Nikita did okay so maybe
you're like me and you need a bit more
of a nudge okay so now look at this I'm
gonna cancel cancel I suggested that
leaves me with this so I'm going to
write one
and then I've got my sign out for Sunday
okay now take advantage of the fact that
they told you exactly what you should
end up with right alfrid readers
supposed to be the same so therefore
what does that indicate to you about
this fraction here this has to be one
right because if I were a reader at the
same angle then this can't be anything
right it would change the ratio sign up
the sign made up almost have to be the
same so to demonstrate that they are the
same right
I'm going to use an identity here right
namely that look at my geometry how many
clothes burn eleven here is P and s dash
and he is P and s and they are
supplementary right they are
supplementary so therefore I'm gonna
write good money and we're right here on
the numerator sign-in page and on that
nominator
they haven't introduced any units as far
as I can see so I'm going to use the
best unit to talk radiance okay and I'm
going to write that as sine pi minus PN
is okay now that there that's a horrible
identity but these two things are the
same ratio okay so therefore under step
2 this is 1 so now being at least to
just cancel with each other that leaves
me with this
now do you my thing sweet I'm there I'm
done ah no what sir careful not so quick
my next line is not out frequency though
because there are an infinite set of
different angles that satisfy this where
alphabet apart the same angle okay
for instance just to be obvious about it
I could say sign offs a pun on 40 and 45
degrees using the way that sign looks
like right like so okay PI n paws like
there
so there's another angle right through
there that'll be three and four right it
should be the same right in fact that's
the whole point of me saying is lying
that sign of platform will be sine of pi
minus three PI over two so these are the
same these are the same so therefore how
can I argue that these are the same or
piece of information am i easy that
again they point the queue well done
that took me some time to say write
alpha beta are not just any angles right
look away their position then nestled
inside an angle formed between the
normal and the tangent so they both have
to be independently because it's a
writing with a and about anything
Alfre beat up must both be less than two
since they are both first quadrant
angles now when you have a look at your
sign okay this is all you've got left
there you go there's the only bit and
the only angles in there which sign up
the same beer are the same i where alpha
and literacy they're for